[Applause]
time for one last dish this is what I'm
liking
we love about Burgers Lobster and sides
has been an awesome day there's a guy in
New York though who's seriously leveling
up the ice cream game for him it's not
just something to eat it's something to
play with so just check this out
[Music]
all right
for years Dylan Rose through the ranks
of tick tock showcasing his ice cream
skills and now he has his very own ice
cream shop in New York City we have him
dialed in from catch and ice cream
watching on NBC4 New York what's up man
how you doing
hi Kelly
so this is kind of been a lifelong
passion right yeah I sort of as a kid
falling in love with ice cream oddly
enough my parents pretty much let us eat
it every night before you go to bed and
then throughout high school and college
I began working at Cold Stone Creamery
where as the pandemic hit I started
creating these videos online of me
making ice cream decorating ice cream
cakes and then even throwing ice them up
into a cup and then those videos went
viral and I gained almost over 50 15
million followers and then now I've been
able to use those followers to support
local businesses and eventually build up
to now where I've opened my own ice
cream shop here in New York City catch
an ice cream that's amazing man
you explain to everybody how catching
ice cream is different each one of our
ice creams come
them and all the time
all the time it kind of looks like
caramel apple we take that and then we
smash it down and mix it all together
for you and if you're down for the
challenge even throw it up to you and
you can try to catch it but don't worry
a few do fall but it's okay at least the
fun reactions like these the most
surprising is when it throws up into the
cup and then it looks like you catch it
but then the ice cream bounces out on
you but we have more interactive things
here to do as well you can come behind
the counter with us and learn how to
make throw and mix up your own ice cream
so next time you're in New York City
come on out and make some ice cream with
us here at Quezon ice cream oh my God I
feel so sorry for your cleaning crew man
that's incredible so thank you so much
Dylan I love that this is your passion
and your purpose and you're following
through
I'm liking your post right now right
awesome appreciate it thank you I love
some rainbow Sprinkles with that picture
okay well that's not all man our season
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 the
go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show one
to honor truly creative and Unstoppable
people just like you do so they are
going to be writing you a check for a
thousand dollars how's that sound
that's amazing thank you so much Kelly
thank you
all right man well thank you so much and
thank you to all our guests this hour
and they're delicious eats Adam Richmond
Stephanie Izard and Burrell
have a great day y'all if it's not
trying to change it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]